effectivement élise je sens des
relations avec l'équipe dans les
mythiques plus de cinq points aux portes
de paris c'est ici que nous a donnés
rendez vous monsieur chaque jour à peu
perdu on est au petit matin il fait déjà
assez chaud on sait pas où on va mais on
y va
nominaux minou et ben voilà il est ici
regardez le la en pleine puces de
saint-ouen ici à clignancourt
ce chat incroyable posée par monsieur
chaque himself et qui est thomas ville
artistes street artiste franco suisse
qui pour la première fois les apposer
ses grands fleurs jaunes en 1997 c'était
à orléans et puis tours et puis ensuite
il ya eu paris genève new york et le
reste du monde
artiste international aujourd'hui est
très coté d'ailleurs vous avez vu entre
le moment où on s'est parlé maintenant
il n'est pas 700 euros à 5000 euros
robin matin il nous reste plus qu'à
attendre le chat enfin monsieur charles
enfin le taux marcquois
[Musique]
vous n'êtes pas monsieur chat c'est vous
c'est pas vous monsieur chat c'est ça
oui c'est moi mais quand tu vois très
bien moi je t'attends depuis tout à
l'heure j'ai eu le temps de voir une de
teaser ici ah oui même vu des gens
devant alors pensez vous monsieur chat
ils ont eu l'honnêteté de dire que
c'était pas attachant si tu vois il
paraît que des ateliers sont ici c'est
ça il ya il montre et y en a trois juste
un deux trois c'était un indice stable
davinci code c'est ça aulas davinci que
tu parles tu es allé par l'atelier allez
vas-y à l'égout
[Musique]
de quoi est ce que tu t'es installé dans
cette ville en particulier dans ce
quartier en fait moi j'ai atterri dans
un endroit j'y suis j'y reste
c'est à tenir c'est ça je me pose pas
plus de questions pourquoi orléans je
suis parti parce que les gens se
rappellent de moi d'ailleurs et toi tu
nous a concocté un itinéraire on va
aller se balader entre ici et paris je
te suis lassé du temps qui me suit c'est
moi qui te suit en insistant un peu
parce que sinon je bois larmes
[Musique]
là c'est le chat qui fait de la télé
c'est un hommage à l'émission renversant
du jour non c'est pas la bonne chaîne
c'est-à-dire au début je les fais pour
m6 après il ya eu tf1 mais là j'ai pas
de bombe
[Musique]
alors là monsieur chat on est toujours à
saint-ouen c'est ça mais dans un
environnement un peu différent de ton
atelier des puces on est sur le quartier
des docks c'est un nouveau quartier
ah ouais c'est moderne tu as vu un et on
retrouve des oeuvres aussi ici mais là
le chat est complètement à l'aise
c'est à dire que ça que bat jusqu'au
bout de du mur là mais explique moi là
est ce que ces vandales tu la fais tu là
posé comme ça tu avais envie de mettre
ici il y avait une petite fête des
voisins et ils m'ont invité
mais ils ont oublié de prévenir la
mairie et donc est ce qui s'est passé
bah le maire il a un petit peu râler
mais je pense qu'il souhaitait vers 11h
je crois qu'il avait pas à manger et
quand a commencé sa carrière au site
avait eu des soucis avec la municipalité
à orléans l'ancien maire d'orléans celui
qui a développé la première campagne
anti graffiti donc de nettoyage des
destructions jusqu'à présent il y avait
pas de politique culturelle là dessus
donc en fait alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est
un art à part entière reconnu à travers
new way c'est un art c'est une économie
et ça commence à s'adresser aux très
grands collectionneurs
même s'il considère que c'est encore
trop populaire est trop vulgaire pour
rentrer dans les grandes collections
académique est classique mais en fait ça
y est ça y va on peut pas arrêter on
peut plus arrêter ce mouvement c'est un
mouvement à part de l'histoire de l'art
donc là on est encore sur quelque chose
d'éphémère
j'en sais rien c'est le temps qu'il dit
ça c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est le
temps qui fait l'oeuvre aussi
moi j'ai pas et puis bah ça reste
n'était pas forcément prévu que ça reste
aussi longtemps
donc c'est de l'éphémère qui dure un peu
comme du préfabriqué quoi c'est un peu
précaire on sait dollar précaire
[Musique]
m
exactement ma chérie
on a traversé le périph on est passé de
saint-ouen dans le 93
au xviiie arrondissement de paris et là
on est dans un quartier que tacle
sillonné de tous les côtés goutte d'or
la barbe est ce surtout le 18e j'aime
beaucoup cet ouvrage des amis
ben oui j'aime bien le 18e un des
arrondissements les plus plus
hospitaliers quoi on va aller découvrir
aussi
quelques chats poser ici et là mais
avant ça quand même
il faut que tu me racontes comment
est-ce qu'il est né ce personnage donc à
l'argonne donc pareil quartiers
périphériques d'orléans j'ai fait de
l'animation
milieu périscolaire et donc à une petite
fille en difficulté scolaire qui un jour
m'a sorti en dessin tout ça et elle
était plutôt exclus et plutôt marginal
d'un groupe d'un moment elles étaient
contentes elles mêmes de m'avoir sortie
ça que j'ai gardées
et c'était un gros chat souriant belle
envie de se démarquer d'humaniser et de
faire des images plutôt que juste
marquer mon nom justement se chargeant
repérer là juste là rien crotte à l'oeil
il est un peu il est un peu lessivé par
le temps non ça c'est ça ouais bah ouais
il n'a pas été effacés c'est le temps
qu'il a fait c'est fait digérée par le
mur cette galerie la bassée chez
jean-marc chez jean-marc l'écomusée en
fait ça fait je suis pas combien 20 ans
qu'il est là il fait vivre le lieu tout
seul est-ce que tu l'as fait
spécialement pour lui ah bah oui c'est
sur son store ou d'alterner toyer la
nuit lors nettoie de temps en temps il
fait sa toilette
mais c'est ça qui m'étonne avec ses
presque de rue c'est que personne en
tout cas sur celui ci
il est venu rejoindre par dessus dans le
milieu du grain pour nettoyer personnes
la police là bas un petit peu mais une
étoile c'est qu'ils sont terrain jean
marc qui tient son terrain tout seul ici
ça expose on est à paris ville monde
vous savez on a dit aussi que monsieur
le chat était à l'international mais
quelquefois le matou revient à la maison
on va justement voir ce que ça donne
maintenant et on se rejoindra après du
côté de belleville un quartier populaire
de padam à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
tous
l'avantagent de là bas aussi que c'est
quand même super vite et a tellement mis
en voix la femme des murs on voit ça me
paraît normal quoi
[Musique]
c'est une forme de pensée active en fait
quand tu pars tu veux tu fais et après
la question c'est qu'est-ce que ça
s'appelait s'appelait pas gens qui vont
être contents je pense d'abord un joli
joli sourire jusqu'à p comme c'est pas
tant
[Musique]
et ce à la hâte en attendant pour en
versant quand même monsieur chat une
toute dernière question orthez comme ça
s'il vous plaît s'il avait une oeuvre un
fantasme tu pourrais faire poser quelque
part ce serait quoi et où
ah bin là une statue une rupture
ouais au jardin de l'évêché à orléans à
orléans c'est un petit truc c'est tout
petit c'était me faites lui plaisir s'il
vous plaît elise un toit cayla dans la
région tu pourrais faire passer le
message s'il te plaît c'est à vous
issoudun où on va griller là ça y est on
y va l'un concernant ben oui on s'est
resserré en solo